una polémica ex figura del fútbol
americano herschelle Walker y Rafael
warnock un pastor con experiencia en el
congreso compiten por el senado en
Georgia la segunda vuelta de este 6 de
diciembre en el estado no cambiará lo
esencial el partido de Joe biden ya
controla la cámara alta pues ya cuentan
con los 50 escaños necesarios más el
voto de desempate en manos de la
vicepresidenta Harris pero llegar a 51
si daría un respiro al partido azul y
ayudaría incluso a contrarrestar a los
demócratas del ala más a la derecha de
la formación como Joe manching de West
Virginia y kirsten Cinema de Arizona que
han bloqueado algunas propuestas
legislativas del ejecutivo
Esta carrera Es sobre competencia y
carácter y mi oponente se queda
Lamentablemente corto en ambos frentes
no ha pasado su vida como si lo he hecho
yo pensando en estos temas y cada vez
que abre la boca se le nota
porque ha sido acusado de abusos contra
las mujeres y de presionarlas para
abortar pero ni eso parece haber mermado
su popularidad forzando a Warner a
publicar 19 anuncios por cada seis de
walker en una de las carreras más caras
del país alguien pensaba que él podría
vencer a Hell walker en un debate porque
él es lo que yo llamo un predicador que
realmente es un falso profeta Walker se
vende Como la forma para arrestar un
voto a los demócratas en el senado y ha
hecho campaña con las victorias
políticas de los demócratas y con la
promesa de defender la democracia una
victoria demócrata en esta última
competencia de los mitters garantizaría
un escaño por seis años daría también a
mayor margen de maniobra al partido de
gobierno en los comités del senado donde
la división en partes iguales con
opositores proyectos legislativos y
nombramientos además de plantear a
Georgia nuevamente como un estado
conquistable para los liberales de Cara
a las elecciones de 2024